This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. In the 2016 Olympics in Rio de Janeiro, the women's 100-meter freestyle race had a favorite. Australia's Kate Campbell. The swimmer had won two bronze medals at the 2008 Olympics and a gold medal at the 2012 Games. One month before Rio, she broke the world record in the 100-meter freestyle.
这是《隐藏的脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。在2016年里约热内卢奥运会上，女子100米自由泳比赛有一个夺冠热门。澳大利亚的凯特·坎贝尔。这位游泳运动员曾在2008年奥运会上获得两枚铜牌，并在2012年奥运会上获得金牌。就在里约奥运会开始前一个月，她打破了100米自由泳的世界纪录。
After that race, she confessed she didn't really know how she did it. I think the best swims you've done from Bethel, so I don't remember a whole lot of it. I just remember getting on the blocks and things like stealing good stuff. Once you got a good start, it's all downhill from there. So I think that's pretty much what I did. And then came Rio. Dave's not working. I'm 100 freestyle final for women. and then came Rio. At first, it looked like she was going to win. Kate's start was a little bit slower than everybody else. The point eight of a second was the reaction time.
赛后，她坦言自己其实并不知道自己是怎么做到的。我认为你游得最好的一次是在贝特尔，所以我记不太清了。我只记得登上起步台，然后事情就跟偷到好东西一样顺利。一旦你开局顺利，接下来就都是顺水推舟了。所以我想这基本上就是我所做的。然后里约奥运会就来了。戴夫没在工作。我是女子100米自由泳决赛。然后里约奥运会就来了。起初，她看起来要赢了。凯特的起步比其他所有人都慢了一点。0.8秒是反应时间。
Once she hit the water, look at the world record line on her waist, a great first 50, 24.77. Kate had a commanding lead. and on her waist, a great first 50, 24.77. Kate had a commanding lead, but after the 50 meter turn, something happened. Her lead began to evaporate. Oh, look, there's quite a few lining up now. This is not clear, has it all? And it's going to be, man.
一旦她入水，看她腰部的世界纪录线，前50米表现出色，24.77秒。凯特取得了领先优势。在她腰部，前50米表现出色，24.77秒。凯特取得了领先优势，但在50米转身后，发生了变化。她的领先优势开始蒸发。哦，看，现在有相当多的人排队了。这可不清楚，全都有吗？这将是，伙计。
In the final sprint, other swimmers edged past her. She ended up in sixth place. Wow, what a shocking result! Later she said, the world got to witness possibly the greatest choke in Olympic history. It turned out, Kate thought she had flinched before the starting gun. A fall start. As she hit the water, she was certain she was going to be disqualified. Her race plan went out the window. She panicked.
在最后的冲刺中，其他游泳运动员超越了她。她最终获得第六名。哇，多么令人震惊的结果！后来她说，全世界可能目睹了奥运史上最伟大的崩盘。事实证明，凯特以为自己在发令枪响前抢跑了。一次犯规起步。当她入水时，她确信自己会被取消资格。她的比赛计划全盘泡汤了。她惊慌失措。
She swam the first 50 meters too fast and then ran out of gas on the home stretch. As the world prepares to watch the planet's finest athletes compete in the Tokyo Olympics, versions of kids' story are likely to be played out over and over again in different sports. The pressure, the nerves, they can get to the very best of the best. Yeah, I mean, it's a little counterintuitive, right? You want to perform at your best. You know how to do it, and you have shown that so many times before.
她前50米游得太快，结果在冲刺阶段精疲力竭。正当全世界准备观看地球上最优秀的运动员在东京奥运会上竞技时，这类故事的版本很可能会在不同的运动项目中不断重演。压力、紧张，它们会击垮最顶尖的精英。是的，我的意思是，这有点违反直觉，对吧？你想发挥出最佳水平。你知道该怎么做，而且你以前已经展示过无数次了。
And then all of a sudden, you just can't pull it off. This week on Hidden Brain, how pressure, hijacks, our bodies, and our brains, and how to keep it from derailing us. All of us have been there, taking the SAT, trying out for the football team, reciting our wedding vows. We all know what it's like to feel hundreds of eyes on us, the pressure, the expectations, the anxiety. At Barnard College in New York,
然后突然之间，你就是做不到了。本周的《隐藏的脑》将探讨压力是如何劫持我们的身体和大脑的，以及如何防止它让我们脱轨。我们所有人都经历过这些，参加SAT考试，为橄榄球队选拔，背诵结婚誓词。我们都知道当几百双眼睛盯着我们时的感觉，压力、期望、焦虑。在纽约的巴纳德学院，
psychologists Cian Bailock has spent decades studying why many of us crumble under pressure and what we can do about it. Cian Bailock, welcome to Hidden Brain. Oh, thanks for having me. See on, you've accomplished a great deal in your life. Besides Stellar career as a psychologist, you've also been a prominent administrator. You're currently the president of Barnard College in New York City.
心理学家西安·贝洛克花了几十年时间研究为什么我们中的许多人会在压力下崩溃以及我们能做些什么。西安·贝洛克，欢迎来到《隐藏的脑》。哦，谢谢邀请我。西安，你在生活中取得了巨大的成就。除了作为心理学家的辉煌职业生涯外，你还是一位杰出的行政管理者。你目前是纽约市巴纳德学院的院长。
But I'd like to take you back to a more humbling moment in your life, if I might. You were in high school, and you were a soccer goalie on the California State team, and you were playing a game. You were in high school and you were a soccer goalie on the California State team and you were playing a game, things were going really well until you noticed someone standing right behind you. What happened next? Yeah, I noticed that the national coach, the person that starts selecting for the Olympic team and playing at that national and world stage was standing right behind me. And all of a sudden, I remember
但我希望能带你回到你生活中一个更令人谦卑的时刻，如果可以的话。你当时上高中，是加州代表队的足球守门员，你正在进行一场比赛。你当时上高中，是加州代表队的足球守门员，你正在进行一场比赛，一切都进行得非常顺利，直到你注意到有人站在你身后。接下来发生了什么？是的，我注意到国家队教练，那个负责选拔奥运会队员并在国家和世界舞台上执教的人，正站在我身后。突然之间，我记得
that my whole mentality changed. I sort of became hyper aware of everything I was doing, and that someone was watching me. I almost was watching myself through his eyes. And I ended up really bobbling the next ball that came to me, and then eventually, I led in an easy shot that I should have been able to block in my sleep.
我的整个心态都变了。我对自己的每一个动作变得高度敏感，意识到有人在看着我。我几乎是通过他的眼睛在审视自己。结果我真的把传给我的下一个球给颠丢了，最后，我放进了一个我本来闭着眼睛都能扑住的简单射门。
It was almost as if it was in slow motion and I just missed, I dove over the ball rather than at the ball. It was almost like getting the ball shot through your legs when you're playing on the field. And the coach walked away, I watched him walk away and I just thought that's it. My soccer career is never gonna be the same,
这几乎就像是在慢动作中，我偏偏没接住，我是扑过球而不是扑向球。这感觉就像你在场上踢球时球从你裆下穿过一样。教练走开了，我看着他走开，心想就这样了。我的足球生涯再也不会和以前一样了，
and I just couldn't understand it. This is something I did all the time. I was a really great player, I practiced so much. Why did this change now when he was there? I was confused and mad and sad. Yeah. We're gonna explore and depth what happens inside the brain when we choke and what we can do about it.
而我就是无法理解。这是我一直在做的事情。我是一个非常出色的球员，我练习了那么多。为什么当他在场时这一切就变了？我又困惑、又生气、又难过。是的。我们将深入探讨当我们崩溃时大脑内部发生了什么以及我们能做些什么。
But I want to begin by clearly laying out the range of ways we can crumble and distress, what sports fans and researchers call choking under pressure. You once experienced this in the academic domain during a chemistry test you took in your freshman year of college. Can you tell me what happens here? Yeah, I choked a lot.
但我想首先明确列出我们崩溃和痛苦的各种表现，体育迷和研究人员称之为压力下崩盘。你曾在学术领域经历过这种事，那是在你读大学一年级时参加的一次化学考试中。你能告诉我这里发生了什么吗？是的，我经常崩盘。
I never tested as well as I did in practice. And this certainly happened when I got to college. I went to the University of California at CNDago. I was focused on getting a Bachelor of Science majoring in a STEM field. And when I went in to take intro to chemistry, which is a very hard class, at least it is for most people.
我的考试表现从来没有像练习时那样好。当我上大学时，这种情况确实发生了。我去了加州大学圣迭戈分校。我专注于获得STEM领域的理学学士学位。当我走进考场参加化学导论时，这是一门非常难的课，至少对大多数人来说是这样。
And the professor looked around at the 600 person class and said, a lot of you aren't gonna pass this class. I thought, oh my God, I'm in that back for sure. Like there's no way. So, I paid attention in class. I thought I'd studied really diligently for the first test.
教授环顾这间坐了600人的教室说，你们很多人都通不过这门课。我想，天哪，我绝对在那个后列。根本不可能。所以，我在课上很专心。我以为我为第一次考试做了非常刻苦的复习。
I took the first test, I walked out and I remember walking behind a group of students and they were talking about the answers. And my answer, I remember thinking, gosh, my answers weren't like their answers. So that was my first cue. Always a bad sign. It was a bad sign. So then, he posted, it wasn't like now where you probably get your scores all online but he posted in like on one of those yellow legal pieces of paper outside the front door. I think maybe even written
我参加了第一次考试，走出来时，我记得自己走在一群学生后面，他们在讨论答案。而我的答案，我记得当时想，天哪，我的答案和他们的不一样。所以那是我的第一个信号。永远是个坏兆头。这是一个不好的兆头。然后，他贴出了成绩，不像现在这样你可能所有的分数都在网上，但他把它贴在前门外面的一张黄色法定纸上。我想甚至可能是手写的
in hand and there were at this point maybe 400 kids in the class and I got the worst grade out of anyone in the class. I mean it's really embarrassing. There were a lot of people tied with me but but there was no one below me. And I remember calling my mom and walking back and saying, I can't do college. I'm not good enough. You know, both the domains in which we've talked about, you know, playing, you know, high stress, you know, soccer game and doing a chemistry test, you know, both the domains in which we've talked about, you know, playing, you know, high stress, you know, soccer game, and doing a chemistry test, you know, you could argue that the tasks involved are actually fairly complex and complicated, but sometimes we can choke even when it comes to doing something simple if the stakes are high enough.
而且当时班里大概有400个孩子，我得了全班最低分。我的意思是这真的很尴尬。有很多人和我同分，但没有一个人在我下面。我记得我一边走一边给我妈妈打电话说，我上不了大学。我不够优秀。你知道，我们所谈论的两个领域，你知道，进行（你知道）高压的（你知道）足球比赛和做化学考试，你知道，我们所谈论的两个领域，你知道，进行（你知道）高压的（你知道）足球比赛和做化学考试，你知道，你可以辩称，其中涉及的任务实际上相当复杂，但有时即使是做简单的事情，如果赌注足够大，我们也会崩溃。
In 2009, US Supreme Court Chief Justice John Roberts was swearing in President-elect Barack Obama. Both men had spent years in the public eye dealing with difficult and stressful situations. The exact words of the oath of office were not a surprise. They were familiar to both men. But here's what happened during the swearing and ceremony. I, Barack Hussein Obama, do solemnly swear. I, Barack Hussein Obama. I'm probably swear. I'm not saying Obama. Do solemnly swear.
2009年，美国最高法院首席大法官约翰·罗伯茨为当选总统贝拉克·奥巴马宣誓就职。两人都在公众视线中度过了多年，处理过困难和有压力的局势。宣誓词的准确字眼并不令人意外。两人都对它们很熟悉。但以下是宣誓仪式期间发生的事情。我，贝拉克·侯赛因·奥巴马，郑重宣誓。我，贝拉克·侯赛因·奥巴马。我可能宣誓。我不是说奥巴马。郑重宣誓。
That I will execute the office of president to the United States faithfully. That I will execute. The office of president of the United States. The office of president of the United States faithfully. And will to the best of my ability. Can you talk a moment, Sihan, about how sometimes the simplest tasks can trip us up when we're under pressure?
我将忠实执行美利坚合众国总统的职务。我将执行。美利坚合众国总统的职务。忠实执行美利坚合众国总统的职务。并尽我最大能力。西安，你能花点时间谈谈，为什么在压力下，最简单的任务也会让我们绊倒吗？
Yeah, I think this is why choking is so interesting, because it can happen in any sort of situation where we feel pressure to perform well. Something, oftentimes, that's so well learned that you would be surprised that anything would go wrong. This, Wearing In, is a great example of that, where maybe the Chief Justice just started paying a little bit too much attention to what he was saying. Just the act of doing that can be really disruptive. One that I like to talk about a lot is parallel parking, which I'm very good at when no one is in the car with me, but when someone is watching, I choke. It's really embarrassing. I, you know, I'm believes me, but I'm a really good parallel Parker to live under stress. It's sort of, it's like one of those philosophical
是的，我认为这就是崩盘如此有趣的原因，因为它可能发生在任何我们感到有压力要表现良好的情况中。有些事情，通常是如此熟练，以至于你会惊讶于任何事情都会出问题。这次宣誓就是一个很好的例子，也许首席大法官只是开始对他说的话给予了过多的关注。仅仅这样做这个动作就会产生很大的干扰。我经常喜欢谈论的一个例子是平行停车，当车里没有别人时我非常擅长，但当有人看着时，我就会崩盘。这真的很尴尬。我，你知道，（相信我，但我是一个非常擅长在压力下生存的平行停车高手）。这有点像那种哲学
conundrums, right? How do we know you're a good parallel Parker? If you're never a good parallel Parker, and we can see. Exactly. It's all about the tree in the forest. Or even one, I think, that's really relevant right now as we come back into social situations is just like interacting with other people. Like, how many times at a party if you tried to introduce yourself and you kind of choke getting the words out or asking someone tells you their name and you have no idea, even as they're saying it what it is.
难题，对吧？我们怎么知道你是个优秀的平行停车手？如果你从来都不是一个优秀的平行停车手，而我们能看到。没错。这完全是关于森林里的树。或者甚至有一个，我认为现在随着我们重新进入社交活动，非常相关，那就是与其他人互动。比如，在聚会上，你试图做自我介绍却说不出话来，或者问别人名字而当他们说出来时你完全不知道是什么，这种情况有多少次？
Like, we choke in the simplest situations. Right. And I want to bring up another example because it's along the lines of what you were just talking about. There are times when we are doing things that we have done hundreds of times before, or thousands of times before, and we still can trip up. I'm thinking of US Army, Buickler, Keith Clark, who performed taps at President John of Kennedy's funeral at Arlington National Cemetery in November 1963.
你看，我们在最简单的情况下也会崩溃。没错。我想提出另一个例子，因为它符合你刚才谈论的内容。有时我们在做我们以前做过数百次或数千次的事情，我们仍然会绊倒。我想到的是美国陆军号手基斯·克拉克，他在1963年11月阿灵顿国家公墓的约翰·F·肯尼迪总统葬礼上吹奏了军号曲。
He'd obviously played it many times before, but something happened when he got to the sixth note. Now, you know, people later said that the mistake, you know, sounded like the bugle was weeping, but Keith Clark himself never got over making this mistake. I suspect that he felt a lot like you felt as you saw the national team coach, you know, walking away from that field. Yeah, I mean, it can be just so devastating to do something that you know how to do and do it not at your level of ability when all eyes are on you. And this is what makes it so mysterious, isn't it?
他显然以前吹过很多次，但当他吹到第六个音符时，发生了点状况。现在，你知道，人们后来评论说那个错误，听起来像军号在哭泣，但基斯·克拉克本人从未从这个错误中走出来。我怀疑他的感受很像你看到国家队教练从球场走开时的感受。是的，我的意思是，当所有眼睛都盯着你时，做一件你知道怎么做却没能达到你能力水平的事，这真的是毁灭性的。这正是它如此神秘的地方，不是吗？
Because when we are going through one of these things, you know, you feel like telling everyone, I really can do it. Believe me, I know how to do this. Yeah, I mean, it's a little counterintuitive, right? You want to perform at your best and you can't, right? It's one thing if you don't care, but choking occurs when you feel the most pressure, you feel everyone's eyes on you, you want to put your best foot forward, you know how to do it, and you have shown that so many times before. And then all of a sudden, you just can't pull it off.
因为当我们经历其中一件事时，你知道，你会有一种想告诉所有人的冲动，我真的能做到。相信我，我知道怎么做。是的，我的意思是，这有点违反直觉，对吧？你想发挥出最佳水平却做不到，对吧？如果你不在乎是一回事，但崩盘发生在你感到压力最大、感到所有人的目光都盯着你、你想展现最好的一面、你知道怎么做并且以前已经展示过无数次的时候。然后突然之间，你就是做不到了。
There are endless examples of professional tennis players and golfers, flubbing simple shots when the pressure is on. Cian soccer story speaks to that. Or take free throws in basketball. So many close games are decided in the final minutes by a player sinking or missing free throws. I mean, I think free throw shooting is such an interesting or missing free throws. Right now he's got to go one for two for a tie. You can't describe the pressure here. I mean, I think free throw shooting is such an interesting aspect of all of my research
有无数的职业网球运动员和高尔夫球手在压力下打丢简单击球的例子。西安的足球故事就说明了这一点。或者以篮球罚球为例。许多势均力敌的比赛都是在最后几分钟由球员罚进或罚丢罚球来决定的。我的意思是，我认为罚球投篮是一个非常有趣或者罚丢的例子。现在他必须两罚一中才能扳平比分。你无法形容这里的压力。我的意思是，我认为罚球投篮是我所有研究中一个非常有趣的方面
and it's like, I think, the epitome of a choke situation. Oh, he missed it! Objectively, shooting a free throw is not that hard of a task compared to what basketball players do. It's the same spot. No one is guarding them. They know how to do it, but what really changes is the psychological element of it. Two shots here, and that one's well-filled off the line.
而且它就像，我认为，是崩盘情况的缩影。哦，他罚丢了！客观地说，与篮球运动员所做的事情相比，罚球并不是一项那么难的任务。位置是一样的。没有人防守他们。他们知道怎么做，但真正改变的是心理因素。这里有两次投篮，那一个偏离了篮筐。
But you see how he pulled back, Jim? He's missed his last two. He is not staying with the shot. As I said, there's a lot of difference making him when you're up by 20. Keeps it a one-thesession game. How big is that? not staying with the shot. As I said, there's a lot of difference making them when you're up by 20. Keeps it a one possession game. How big is that? But sports also shows us another domain of choking
但你看到他是如何退缩的吗，吉姆？他已经连续罚丢两个了。他没有坚持完成投篮。正如我所说，当你领先20分时，进球有很大的不同。保持分差在一个Possession（球权）之内。那有多大意义？没有坚持完成投篮。正如我所说，当你领先20分时，进球有很大的不同。保持分差在一个球权之内。那有多大意义？但体育运动也向我们展示了崩盘的另一个领域
where the choke isn't over in just a moment where you let in a goal, but the choke sort of builds on itself. It becomes bigger and bigger. In your book, choke, you tell the story of the French golfer, Jean Van Develle at the British Open in 1999. What happened to him, Sia? He got to that 18th hole. He was just ready to win. He's three shots ahead, so he can afford to take a six and still win double bowgit and still then he should five over.
在这个领域中，崩盘并不是在让你进一个球的瞬间就结束的，而是崩盘本身在不断积累。它变得越来越大。在你的书《崩盘》中，你讲述了法国高尔夫球手让·范德维尔在1999年英国公开赛上的故事。他怎么了，西安？他到了第18洞。他正准备获胜。他领先三杆，所以他完全可以吞下一个六杆（柏忌）甚至双柏忌（double bogie）还能赢，然后他...
But you could see, right when he got to the 18th hole, everything looked a little different. He sat over the ball before he took his first drive and it did not go well. His first shot on the 18th hole landed on the fairway of the 17th hole. The second off the grandstand, the third into the water. the 17th hole, the second off the grandstand, the third into the water, and you can see the picture that was across newspapers the next day. He took off his socks and shoes and waited into the water and was actually going to try and hit the ball out of the water. Now I don't know, we've many of us have tried these kind of shots, but he's going to sink deeper and deeper, but it's all silty down here, and I don't think he's... And he faintly decided not to do that, took the penalty,
但你可以看到，就在他到达第18洞时，一切看起来都有点不同。他在打第一杆之前坐在球上方，结果很不理想。他在第18洞的第一杆落在了第17洞的球道上。第二杆打到了看台上，第三项打进水里。在第17洞，第二杆打到了看台上，第三杆打进水里，你可以看到第二天各大报纸上的照片。他脱下袜子和鞋子，涉水走进水里，实际上打算把水里的球击打出来。现在我不知道，我们中的许多人都尝试过这种类型的击球，但他会越陷越深，但下面全是淤泥，而且我不认为他……他最终决定不那样做，接受了罚杆，
ended up in a tiebreaker round and lost. This is so, so, so, so sad. But he just crumbled. Not only did his shot start going awry, but you kind of felt like it was building on each other. You had the sense that it was not going in a good direction and it's just heartbreaking. His golfing brain stopped about 10 minutes ago, I think.
结果进入了加时赛并输了。这真是太、太、太、太悲伤了。但他就是崩溃了。不仅他的击球开始出现偏差，而且你隐约觉得它们是在彼此叠加。你有一种感觉，事情没有朝好的方向发展，这简直令人心碎。他的高尔夫大脑大约在10分钟前就停止运转了，我想。
Yeah, I don't know if you feel the same way, Siambo, whenever I see something like this on television or I hear something, I feel terrible. It's like, I feel like, oh my god, I just want this to end. Please fix the problem. And do you feel that way that in some ways, you're with them in this moment of excruciating agony? Oh, I feel it with them right there. In a way, though, I've learned not only to feel the excruciating pain,
是的，我不知道你是否有同感，西安，每当我在电视上看到这样的事情或听到这样的事情时，我都觉得太糟糕了。就像，我觉得，哦天哪，我只想让这一切结束。请解决这个问题。你是否有这种感觉，在某种程度上，你在这个极其痛苦的时刻与他们同在？哦，我就和他们一起在那里感受着。不过，在某种程度上，我不仅学会了去感受那种极致的痛苦，
but I kind of look at it as a scientist. I'm really interested in what's going to happen next. Yeah. And I think that's actually one of the reasons we love watching sports, right? We know that people come into professional games often or amateur games with high skill levels, but you never quite know what's going to happen when it mistakes are highest. I mean, if you just knew how people were going to play based on their past records, why would
而且我开始以科学家的视角来看待它。我真的很想知道接下来会发生什么。是的。我认为这实际上是我们喜欢看体育比赛的原因之一，对吧？我们知道人们进入职业比赛或业余比赛时往往具备很高的技能水平，但当赌注最高时，你永远不知道会发生什么。我的意思是，如果你仅仅根据过去的记录就能知道人们会如何表现，为什么还要
you watch, right? But what's so interesting is that at those highest levels, there's a mental aspect that you just don't know how it's going to play out. Who's going to choke? Who's going to thrive? Can someone recover? And it's just so fascinating from a human perspective. I want to talk about a slightly different element of choking. Sometimes when we choke, it can produce breakdowns in communication. For example, in medicine or surgery, or when a team is working on something complex, can you talk about this that sometimes choking is not just about what happens to you, but
观看呢？但最有趣的是，在最高水平的比赛中，有一种心理层面，你根本不知道事情会如何发展。谁会崩盘？谁会盛开？有人能恢复过来吗？从人性的角度来看，这真是太迷人了。我想谈谈崩盘的一个略有不同的元素。有时当我们崩盘时，它会导致沟通中断。例如，在医学或外科手术中，或者当团队在处理复杂的事情时，你能谈谈这一点吗，有时崩盘不仅仅是发生在你身上的事情，而是
what happens to you as a member of a team in terms of your interactions with other people on the team? Yeah, I mean, I think this is a really interesting aspect of choking, right? Choking can be very individual, but we often don't work as individuals. You know, often we're working as teams, and one thing that my research and others have shown is that one of the key places that there are performance breakdowns when they're stressful situations, time demands, or there's life or death situations, is that people stop communicating as well as they could. And this is really interesting because doctors, for example, they don't communicate all the information to another doctor as they hand off a patient, and then there's an issue, or pilots leave something out,
作为团队成员，你与团队中其他人的互动方面发生在你身上的事情？是的，我的意思是，我认为这是崩盘的一个非常有趣的方面，对吧？崩盘可能是非常个人化的，但我们通常不是作为个人在工作。你知道，通常我们是以团队的形式在工作，我的研究和其他人的研究表明，当出现压力情况、时间要求或生死攸关的情况时，表现出现故障的关键地方之一，就是人们停止了尽可能好的沟通。这非常有趣，因为例如医生，他们在交接病人时没有将所有信息传达给另一位医生，然后就会出现问题，或者飞行员遗漏了某些东西，
a hand off a patient, and then there's an issue, or pilots leave something out, or even as you're working as a team on a group project, you fail to communicate in a way that's clear. And what I find so interesting about these situations is that we're often very confident that we've communicated what we need to communicate because we know what it is in our head. But our ability to accurately gauge
交接病人，然后出现问题，或者甚至当你作为一个团队进行小组项目时，你未能以清晰的方式进行沟通。我对这些情况感到非常有趣的是，我们通常非常自信我们已经传达了我们需要传达的内容，因为我们脑海中知道它是什么。但我们准确评估
whether or someone else understood it is what gets diminished. We often think that people who fail at important tasks are people who don't care or people who are simply unprepared for the big moment. When we come back, how choking is often not the product of carelessness and inexperience, but the consequence of expertise and caring too much. You'll listen to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. Even the most experienced and skilled musicians, athletes, and doctors can sometimes lose it. They crumble unexpectedly and find themselves bewildered at what happened.
别人是否理解的能力却减弱了。我们经常认为在重要任务上失败的人是那些不在乎的人或是根本没有为大时刻做好准备的人。稍后回来，我们将探讨崩盘往往不是粗心大意和缺乏经验的产物，而是专业技能和过度关心的后果。你正在收听《隐藏的脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。即使是最经验丰富、技能娴熟的音乐家、运动员和医生有时也会失控。他们出乎意料地崩溃，对发生的事情感到迷惑不解。
They know how to do something really well. So why did their skills abandon them when it mattered most? See on Bailock has studied the psychology of choking. She and other researchers have discovered that there is a complex psychology behind this all-too-common experience. In her book, she explores the role of what cognitive scientists call working memory in the phenomenon of joking. I mean, I think about our working memory as like our cognitive horsepower, right? It allows us to get lots of things done, juggle numbers in our head, plan for the future,
他们知道如何把某件事做得很好。那么，当事情最重要的时候，为什么他们的技能却离他们而去呢？西安·贝洛克研究了崩盘的心理学。她和其他研究人员发现，这种极其普遍的体验背后存在着复杂的心理学。在她的书中，她探讨了认知科学家所说的工作记忆在崩盘现象中所扮演的角色。我的意思是，我把我们的工作记忆想象成我们的认知马力，对吧？它让我们能够完成很多事情，在脑海中处理数字，为未来做计划，
make decisions based on a lot of different information, and the thing that is so important to remember about working memories that it's limited, we only have so much of it, which is why, for example, it's not a good idea to drive and talk on the cell phone because then part of your working memory is devoted to reacting to what's happening on the road. And another part of it is devoted to the cell phone conversation, and that's not great.
根据大量不同的信息做出决策，关于工作记忆，有一点非常重要，必须记住，它是有限的，我们的容量只有那么多，这就是为什么，例如，边开车边打手机不是个好主意，因为这样你的一部分工作记忆要用来对路上的情况做出反应。而另一部分则用于手机对话，这可不太好。
So psychologists have come up with a number of ways to identify and test working memory. Can you tell me how they do this, John? Yeah, well, it's really getting you to work as you're thinking about something. So maybe I'll read you a list of digits and you have to repeat them back to me just as I read them. So that's kind of how much you can hold.
因此，心理学家想出了许多方法来识别和测试工作记忆。你能告诉我他们是怎么做到的吗，约翰？是的，这实际上是让你在思考某事时进行工作。所以我可能会给你读一串数字，你必须像我读的那样把它们复述给我。所以这有点像你能记住多少。
But what if I read you a list of digits and then you had to repeat them back in the reverse order? Why? That's a lot harder, right? Because you have to hold all the digits and then you had to repeat them back in the reverse order, that's a lot harder, right? Because you have to hold all the digits, then you have to start counting backwards while still not getting rid of any of what you've held. And that's really the working part of working memory. Because working memory is finite, your brain has to quickly decide how to deploy it.
但如果我给你读一串数字，然后你必须把它们倒序复述出来呢？为什么？这难得多，对吧？因为你必须记住所有的数字，然后你必须把它们倒序复述出来，这难得多，对吧？因为你必须记住所有的数字，然后你必须开始倒着数，同时还不能丢掉你记住的任何东西。这才是工作记忆中真正“工作”的部分。由于工作记忆是有限的，你的大脑必须迅速决定如何分配它。
In a basketball game, your brain has to take in where your teammates are located, what your opponents are doing. It has to figure out how to respond to a new opportunity that suddenly develops. One reason skilled players are better than novices is because they have seen similar situations on the court before. So they don't expend a lot of working memory to process what is happening. They can focus their working memory on the elements of the situation that are truly novel. Yeah, I mean, I think that's what really separates those extraordinary performers from us regular ones, like a concert pianist is not thinking about what their fingers are doing, and because they don't
在一场篮球比赛中，你的大脑必须掌握队友的位置、对手在做什么。它必须弄清楚如何应对突然出现的新机会。熟练球员比新手表现更好的原因之一，是因为他们在球场上见过类似的境况。因此，他们不需要消耗大量的工作记忆来处理正在发生的事情。他们可以将工作记忆集中在情况中真正新颖的那些要素上。是的，我的意思是，我认为这正是那些非凡的表演者与我们这些普通人真正区别开来的地方，比如音乐会钢琴家不会去想他们的手指在做什么，正因为他们不需要去想
have to think about that, they can then interpret the melody and think about how the tone is in particular situations and have an impact with a piece that you or I who's having and think about how the tone is in particular situations and have an impact with a piece that you or I who's having to think about our fingers would not be able to. I'm wondering, Sihan, if we can talk a moment about the paradox of working memory, because of course the picture that you're laying out suggests that having working memory is very effective, that it helps us in all kinds of different domains. And of course on the face of it, that is true, but the answer is also more complicated. Can you explain how?
去想这个，他们就可以去诠释旋律，考虑在特定情况下的音色应该如何，并对一段作品产生影响，而你或我这种必须考虑手指的普通人是无法做到这一点的。我想知道，西安，我们能否花一点时间讨论一下工作记忆的悖论，因为你所勾勒出的图景当然表明，拥有工作记忆是非常有效的，它在各种不同的领域都能帮助我们。当然，表面上看，这是真的，但答案也更复杂。你能解释一下是如何复杂的吗？
Yeah, I mean, so here's really the kicker. It's really important to be able to focus, but you have to be focusing on the right things. And what often happens is that when we're performing skills or activities where it's actually, we've learned them to perfection or learn them on autopilot, it's better not to focus on all the details. So sometimes our working memory can actually get in the way. And let me just give you an example. Most of us, who are fortunate enough, could shuffle down the stairs really easily
是的，我的意思是，这里真正的关键来了。能够专注于目标非常重要，但你必须专注于正确的事情。而经常发生的情况是，当我们执行那些我们已经学到完美或学成自动驾驶的技能或活动时，最好不要关注所有的细节。所以有时我们的工作记忆实际上会妨碍我们。让我举个例子。我们大多数人，如果足够幸运的话，能够非常轻松地走下楼梯
and not give it a second thought. We've learned walking motions and locomotion in a way that we just don't think about what we're doing. But if I ask you to pay attention to your knee and tell me what your knee is doing is you're shuffling down the stairs, there's a good chance you're gonna fall down the stairs. Because now I'm asking you to bring into conscious attention
而不用再想第二遍。我们学习走路动作和移动的方式使得我们根本不用去想我们在做什么。但如果我让你注意你的膝盖，并告诉我当你走下楼梯时你的膝盖在做什么，你很有可能会从楼梯上摔下来。因为现在我要求你把原本通常在潜意识中运行的事情
something that normally runs outside it. And you might in doing so, just take a little longer and thinking how your knee is gonna be placed and that's when you fall. I'm wondering if this is what might explain why, in many sports, the same thing that helps you in one domain of the game can actually hurt you in another domain of the game. Because there actually are times when you should be focusing and should be concentrating
带入有意识的注意中。你可能会在这样做的时候，稍微多花一点时间去思考你的膝盖将如何放置，而这正是你摔倒的时候。我想知道这是否能解释为什么在许多运动中，在比赛的一个领域对你有帮助的同一件事，实际上可能会在另一个领域伤害你。因为确实有时你应该集中注意力，
and should be conscious, and there are other times when, in fact, being conscious and deliberate can hurt you. Yeah, I mean, I think that's right. What I would even say is that, you know, there are certain things that you need to be conscious and focusing on and certain things that you don't, even within the same activity. So you'd want your basketball player certainly to be using working memory to read the court, think about the next play going on, how they're going to move after that play, but you certainly wouldn't want the player at that point to be thinking about how they're angling their wrist as they go to take the shot, because that's something they do so fluently.
并且应该是有意识的，但也有其他时候，实际上，有意识和刻意反而会伤害你。是的，我的意思是，我认为这是对的。我甚至想说，你知道，有些事情你需要有意识地去关注，而有些事情则不需要，即使在同一项活动中也是如此。所以你当然希望你的篮球运动员在阅读球场时使用工作记忆，思考接下来的战术，以及在那之后他们将如何移动，但你当然不希望运动员在那个时候去想他们在投篮时手腕的角度，因为那是他们做得非常熟练的事情。
It's actually going to slow them down to have to think about it consciously to use their working memory. You write in the book that the key is to have brain power at your disposal, but be able to turn it off when that brain power is a problem. And I thought that was such an interesting idea that on the one hand, you want to have the ability, you want to have the working memory, but you also want to in some ways have it be like a faucet where you can turn it off and go back to autopilot. I think that's right,
并且应该有意识，而有时事实上，有意识和刻意反而会伤害你。是的，我的意思是，我想是这样的。我甚至会说，你知道，有些事情你需要有意识地去关注，而有些事情你不需要，即使在同一个活动中也是如此。所以你肯定希望你的篮球球员利用工作记忆来观察球场，思考接下来的战术，思考他们在战术之后将如何移动，但你肯定不希望球员在这个时候去思考他们在投篮时手腕的角度如何，因为那是他们做得非常流畅的事情。
and I think it gets back to this idea that more attention concentrating more is not always helpful. And I always cringe when I hear coaches yelling at kids from the side of the line, concentrate, concentrate. I mean, it may be true for the kid on the soccer field who's watching the plane fly above them. But oftentimes, you know, in that pressure situation,
并且我认为这回归到了这样一个观点，即更多的注意力和更集中的精神并不总是会有帮助。每当我听到教练在场边对孩子们大喊“集中注意力，集中注意力”时，我总是感到局促不安。我的意思是，对于那个在足球场上看着飞机从头顶飞过的孩子来说，这可能是真的。但通常情况下，你知道，在那种压力情境下，
you don't wanna encourage the players to pay too much attention to things that they shouldn't. Yeah. So in some ways we can go back to your high school soccer game here. You know, when you were thinking about what the coach was thinking of you, in some ways, and you started to analyze your own behavior, and analyze your own performance, you were watching yourself from outside yourself.
你不会想鼓励球员去过多关注他们不该关注的事情。是的。所以在某种程度上，我们可以回到你当年的高中足球赛。你知道，当你当时在想教练是怎么看你的时候，在某种程度上，当你开始分析自己的行为并分析自己的表现时，你其实是在从局外审视自己。
I mean, this is what you call paralysis by analysis. It really is. And I think when I did it at the time, I had this feeling of everything going in slow motion. I was paying attention in a way I don't normally do. And it wasn't until many years later, when I started researching this, where I realized this is actually a common phenomenon in these high-stakes situations we care so much about what we're doing, that we try and control it in order to ensure an optimal performance. And unfortunately,
我的意思是，这就是所谓的“过度分析导致瘫痪”。确实如此。而且我想我当时这么做的时候，有一种一切都在慢动作中进行的感觉。我在以一种平时不会有的方式集中注意力。直到多年后，当我开始研究这个课题时，我才意识到这其实是高风险情境中的一种常见现象——我们太在意自己的所作所为，以至于试图控制它以确保最佳表现。而不幸的是，
that control can backfire and actually disrupt our ability to play fluently on autopilot, to do the thing we've practiced so hard to do. I want to talk about some research studies that you and others have conducted where you can actually induce choking or something that looks like choking in people. You've conducted studies where you ask college soccer players, for example, to dribble a ball around cones while noticing with side of their feet, they are using to control the ball.
这种控制可能会适得其反，并实际上破坏我们开启自动驾驶、流利地进行比赛的能力，破坏我们苦练已久的事情。我想谈谈你和其他人进行的一些研究，在这些研究中，你们实际上可以诱发人们“发发挥失常”或看起来像失常的现象。你们曾进行过这样的研究，例如，要求大学足球球员围绕锥桶运球，同时注意他们是用脚的哪一侧来控制球的。
Tell me about the study and what you found. Yeah, I've done a lot of studies designed to try and make people perform worse. But in this situation, we had soccer players who were either new to soccer novices or just very inexperienced dribble-around cones, and we also had college-level players, or really expert players do the same thing. And we told them both to pay attention to the side of the foot that just touched the ball. And what we found is that for the experts,
跟我讲讲这项研究以及你们的发现。是的，我做过很多旨在试图让人们表现得更差的研究。但在这种情况下，我们让刚接触足球的新手或经验不足的球员围绕锥桶运球，同时也让大学水平的球员或真正的专家球员做同样的事情。我们告诉他们双方都要注意刚刚触球的那一侧脚。而我们发现，对于专家来说，
doing that actually slowed down their ability to dribble through the cones accurately. But for the novices, if anything, it helped a little bit. And it goes back to this idea that, for the most part, when we're just learning a skill, we do have to pay attention to it a lot. But once we know it really well, and it's on autopilot, if you pay too much attention to aspects of it that you wouldn't normally focus on, there's no soccer player in college
这样做实际上减慢了他们准确穿过锥桶运球的能力。但对于新手来说，如果说有什么影响的话，那甚至还有点帮助。这就回到了这样一个观点：在绝大多数情况下，当我们刚刚学习一项技能时，我们确实需要对它投入大量注意力。但一旦我们对它了如指掌，并且它已经进入自动驾驶状态，如果你对平时不会刻意关注的方面投入太多注意力——在大学足球比赛中，没有哪个球员会
soccer running down the field thinking about left, right, left, right, that you actually disrupt it. So this is the great paradox of working memory. It plays an essential role as we're learning a new skill. Being deliberate and conscious when you're a beginner is an excellent way to master something. But as you get better and better, it becomes more and more automatic. Instead of working memory, you now need to rely on something called procedural memory. All the things you know how to do really well are saved in your brain in procedural memory. If you take a skill that has been encoded in procedural memory and start to think about it deliberately using working memory, you go back to thinking like a beginner.
一边在场上奔跑，一边想着“左、右、左、右”——你实际上会破坏它。所以这就是工作记忆的巨大悖论。在我们学习新技能时，它起着至关重要的作用。当你是初学者时，刻意和有意识是掌握某项技能的绝佳方式。但随着你变得越来越好，它会变得越来越自动化。你现在不需要依赖工作记忆，而是需要依赖所谓的程序性记忆。所有你非常擅长的技能都保存在你的大脑程序性记忆中。如果你拿一项已经编码在程序性记忆中的技能，开始用工作记忆刻意去思考它，你就会重新像初学者一样思考。
This is when you choke. Yeah, I mean, I think one important take home is that we have different kinds of memory or we talk about remembering in different ways. And procedural memory characterizes more our memory for different procedures, right? And so we don't think about every step as we get really good at it. We can do the whole procedure together. We just sort of get at the end. It's kind of like the route you take to go to work every day, when we did at one point
这就是你发挥失常的时候。是的，我的意思是，我认为一个重要的结论是，我们有不同种类的记忆，或者我们以不同的方式谈论记忆。程序性记忆更能体现我们对不同程序的记忆，对吧？所以当我们变得非常擅长它时，我们不会去想每一步。我们可以把整个程序作为一个整体来完成。我们只是在最后顺理成章地达成。这有点像你每天上班走的路线，当我们在某个特定时期
commute to work, you don't think about every turn you make. All of a sudden you end up at work and you're there. And that's sort of a procedure you have memorized to do something. And it's the same in athletics as well as you get much better and better at doing a particular task. The memory is, we talk about it as this procedural memory, it's sort of you remember the procedures to do it and you can start at the beginning and end at the end. You don't have to think about the steps in between.
通勤上班时，你不会去想你转的每一个弯。突然之间你到了公司，你就已经在那里了。这有点像你为了做某事而记住的一个程序。在田径运动中也是如此，随着你越来越擅长执行某个特定的任务。这种记忆，我们称之为程序性记忆，它有点像你记住了完成它的程序，你可以从头开始并在结尾结束。你不必去想中间的步骤。
Researchers have also found that when we are under pressure, other cognitive skills get disrupted. In one study, scientists scan the brains of Cornell medical students experiencing the stress of preparing for their board exams. The students underperformed in a simple test of cognitive ability. The researchers tracked what was happening inside their brains. And what they found is that, you know, different areas of their brain were not communicating as well with each other as they should. It was almost as if, being under that constant stress head, disrupted the fluent flow of information nearly. And it led these students, the ones who are getting ready for the boards, to be less creative, less able to think
研究人员还发现，当我们处于压力下时，其他认知技能也会受到干扰。在一项研究中，科学家们扫描了正在经历准备执业资格考试压力的康奈尔医学院学生的脑部。这些学生在简单的认知能力测试中表现不佳。研究人员追踪了他们大脑内部发生的事情。他们发现，你知道，他们大脑的不同区域之间无法像往常那样进行良好的沟通。这就好像处于那种持续的压力之下，几乎破坏了信息流动的流畅性。它导致这些学生——那些正准备考试的学生——变得更缺乏创造力，更没有能力去思考
outside the box, less able to solve interesting problems. So much of what we're talking about, Cion, comes down to the role that anxiety is playing in our lives. You once conducted a study into math anxiety and looked at the changes happening in people's brains as they were about to embark on a math test. Yeah, so we've done a lot of work lately looking at math anxiety because unfortunately math anxiety is really prevalent and we've been really interested in where math anxiety comes from and what's actually happening when someone whose math anxious has to do math.
条框之外的问题，解决有趣问题的能力也变差了。西恩，我们谈论的很多内容都归结为焦虑在我们生活中扮演的角色。你曾经做过一项关于数学焦虑的研究，并观察了人们在准备参加数学测试时大脑中发生的变化。是的，所以我们最近做了很多关于数学焦虑的研究，因为不幸的是数学焦虑非常普遍，我们一直对数学焦虑的来源以及数学焦虑症患者在必须做数学题时大脑中实际发生的情况非常感兴趣。
And our argument has been that it's not just that people who are anxious about math are bad at it, that something about the anxiety itself changes how the brain functions. And so we looked at that by inviting people who are really worried about math and people who weren't to our lab to have their brain scanned using an MRI. And what was so interesting about this study and about using neuroscience technique here is that we could really separate out what was happening in the brain about being anxious from actually what was going on in the brain when they were doing the math. And you can actually get a picture of which areas of the brain are changing when someone
我们的论点一直是，不仅仅是那些对数学感到焦虑的人不擅长数学，而是焦虑本身改变了大脑运作的方式。因此，我们通过邀请真正担心数学的人和不担心数学的人来到我们的实验室，用核磁共振扫描他们的大脑来研究这一点。这项研究以及在这里使用神经科学技术的有趣之处在于，我们可以真正区分出大脑中由焦虑引起的部分，以及他们在做数学题时大脑中实际发生的事情。你可以真正拍下当某人......时大脑中哪些区域正在发生变化的图片
just knows they're about to do math versus when they're actually doing it. And so what we did is we told them, they would get a cue, like maybe a yellow square and they knew the math was about to come, or they'd get another cue or red square and they knew they were gonna do a reading task. And what we found, which was really interesting, was when the people who were really worried about math
只是知道自己即将要做数学题，与他们实际上在做数学题时的对比。因此我们所做的是，我们告诉他们，他们会得到一个提示，比如可能是一个黄色的方块，他们就知道数学题要来了，或者他们会得到另一个提示，比如一个红色的方块，他们就知道他们将要做一个阅读任务。而我们发现的非常有趣的事情是，那些非常担心数学的人
just knew the math was coming, areas of the brain involved in our neural pain matrix, the same areas of the brain that are involved when we pick our finger with a needle or stub or toe were activated. When they just knew the math was coming, they weren't doing any math, they just knew it was coming. But even more interesting was that when these areas of the brain were active, when they just knew the math was coming, when they actually had to do the math, they did worse. It's almost as if the pain is now sort of, or the anticipation of pain is sort of crowding
仅仅是知道数学题要来了，我们大脑中参与神经疼痛矩阵的区域——也就是那些在我们用针扎破手指或脚趾撞到东西时会被激活的大脑区域——就被激活了。当他们仅仅知道数学要来的时候，他们并没有在做任何数学题，他们只是知道它要来。但更有趣的是，当大脑的这些区域活跃时，也就是说当他们仅仅知道数学要来时，当他们真正必须去做数学题时，他们考得更糟。这几乎就好像是这种疼痛现在，或者说对疼痛的预期，正在某种程度上挤占
out their ability to actually focus on the problem. So at some point now they're not actually looking at the math problem anymore because their brain is so filled with the pain or the fear of the impending pain. And that's really been our argument that people who are anxious about math are not anxious because they're bad at it. They're bad at math because they're anxious about it. And that's really been our argument that people who are anxious about math are not anxious because they're bad at it. They're bad at math because they're anxious about it. And that's a very, very different story about how to help people get better at it. These feelings of anxiety often come from a desire to do well.
了他们真正专注于问题的能力。所以在某个时刻，他们实际上不再看数学题了，因为他们的大脑被疼痛或对即将到来的疼痛的恐惧填满了。这确实一直是我们的论点，即对数学感到焦虑的人并不是因为他们不擅长数学才焦虑。他们是因为对数学感到焦虑才不擅长数学。这确实一直是我们的论点，即对数学感到焦虑的人并不是因为他们不擅长数学才焦虑。他们是因为对数学感到焦虑才不擅长数学。对于如何帮助人们在这方面做得更好，这是一个非常非常不同的故事。这种焦虑感往往源于一种做好的渴望。
The solution to choking cannot be to stop caring. When we come back, techniques we can all learn to keep caring, but stop choking. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. Psychologist Cian Bailaac has found that in high-stakes settings, many of us start to focus on the wrong things. Instead of simply executing what we know how to do, we second-guess ourselves and behave in highly scripted and stilted ways. Unsurprisingly, we make mistakes.
解决发挥失常的办法绝不能是不在乎。当我们回来时，我们将探讨我们所有人都可以学习的技术，以保持在乎，但不再发挥失常。你收听的是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。心理学家西恩·贝拉克发现，在高风险的环境中，我们许多人开始关注错误的事情。我们没有简单地执行我们知道该如何做的事情，而是自我怀疑，并以高度刻板和不自然的方式行事。毫不奇怪，我们犯了错误。
And when we do mess up, our mistakes can then make us even more anxious. To choke might be human, but there are some people who perform remarkably well under pressure. When the stakes are highest, they don't crumble. They actually seem to thrive. Sion is performing well under pressure a matter of temperament or a skill that we can all learn. Yeah, well I've really fall strongly on these are skills that can be learned side. Of course there are many individual differences across people and one is, you know, maybe how susceptible they are to what other people think about them or how much they care about a particular domain or area, but I don't think there's very much evidence at all that people are chokers or thrivers and I think anyone can learn to perform better at what makes them most nervous when the pressure is on. We
而当我们搞砸时，我们的错误反倒会让我们更加焦虑。发挥失常或许是人之常情，但有些人却能在压力下表现得异常出色。当风险最高时，他们没有崩溃。他们实际上似乎在茁壮成长。西恩，在压力下表现出色是取决于气质，还是我们所有人都能学会的一项技能？是的，嗯，我非常坚定地站在这些是可以学习的技能这一边。当然，不同的人之间存在许多个体差异，其中一个差异可能是，你知道的，他们对其他人如何看待他们有多敏感，或者他们对某个特定领域或领域的在乎程度有多高，但我认为几乎没有什么证据表明有人天生就会发挥失常或天生能在压力下表现出色，而且我认为任何人都可以学习在压力来临时，在让他们最紧张的事情上表现得更好。我们
talked a little about that chemistry test in college that you did really badly at. You came in last in a class of 400. After the test was over, you had a conversation with your mom where you expressed to her concerns about whether you were the right fit for college. And she suggested a number of things to you that turned out to actually be quite relevant in actually turning you from a choker to a driver. What was that conversation like and what did she tell you, Sia? Yeah, so I remember calling her as I was walking back to my dorm after getting the score and you know, I was just devastated and I thought I'd done everything right, but she asked just the right questions. She said, did you study? I said, of course I studied. She said, did you do the practice problems in the book? I said, no, I just read over the
稍微聊了聊你在大学里考得非常糟糕的那门化学考试。你在一个400人的班级里考了最后一名。考试结束后，你和妈妈进行了对话，向她表达了你对是否适合上大学的担忧。她向你提出了很多建议，事实证明这些建议实际上非常具有相关性，真的让你从一个容易发挥失常的人变成了一个能在压力下大显身手的人。那次对话是怎样的？她对你说了什么，西恩？是的，所以记得当我拿到成绩走回宿舍时我给她打电话，你知道的，我当时简直心碎了，我以为我每个环节都做对了，但她问了恰到好处的问题。她说，你复习了吗？我说，我当然复习了。她说，你做了书里的练习题吗？我说，没有，我只是把章节读了一遍。她说，你有学习小组吗？你有跟其他人核对过看你是否懂了吗？我说，没有，我都是自己一个人做的。她说，你去了答疑时间吗？我说，没有，没有，我只是像在高中时那样读了书，我在高中时考得非常好。她说，好吧，也许你只是复习的方法不对。我把她的建议听进去了。我意识到我必须去做一些我原本不喜欢做的事情，那就是做练习题，这些练习题可一点也不好玩。
chapters. And she said, did you have a study group? Did you see if you knew things with like other people knew them? I said, no, I just did it all by myself. She said, did you go to office hours? I said, no, no, I just read the book like I did in high school and I did really well in high school. She said, well, maybe you just didn't study in the right way. And I took her advice to hard. I realized that I had to do something that I didn't like to do, which were the practice problems, which were not fun.
我找了一个学习小组，这对于了解我懂什么、不懂什么很有帮助。但当我真正弄清楚如何用正确的方法做到这一点时，是我会先自己独自学过之后再去参加学习小组，然后我们互相提问。也就是我会先自己学过之后再去参加学习小组，然后我们互相提问，就像尽最大努力以最快的速度得出答案一样，这就像我们在那个小组里模拟参加考试一样。正是在那个时候，我真正掌握了这些题目。
And I found a study group, which was helpful to understand what I knew and what I didn't. But when I really figured out how to do this in the right way was that I would go to the study sessions having already studied on my own and we'd quiz each other. that I would go to the study sessions having already studied on my own and we'd quiz each other, like trying to get to the answers as quickly as possible and it was like we were mimicking, taking the test in that group. And that's when I really mastered the problems.
事实证明，要在压力下表现出色，一个非常棒的技巧就是练习在压力下表现出色。当我们参加第二次考试时，我考了全班最高分。哇。据我了解，你也一直在帮自己的孩子内化同样的教训，换句话说，你可以在真正承受压力之前，尝试模拟压力情境，以便在情况真正出现时帮助自己应对。是的，我的意思是，如果我10岁的女儿要在课堂上做展示，我经常会让她对着我做，你知道的，有时我会开一些好笑的玩笑，或者稍微分散一下她的注意力，让她习惯课堂上可能会发生的情况，没有什么比让妈妈感到尴尬和烦扰更能制造压力了。所以当她站在小组面前时，她就已经做好准备了。因此在某种程度上，在我看来，这与普遍对抗焦虑的理念不谋而合，那就是接触能引发焦虑的触发因素，往往是减少我们对焦虑反应的最佳方式。
And it turns out that that's a really great technique to do well under pressure is to practice doing well under pressure. And when we took the second test, I got the highest grade in the class. Wow. I understand you've helped your own children internalize the same lesson, that in other words, you can actually try and mimic pressure situations before you're actually under pressure in order to help you deal with a situation when it actually arises. Yeah, I mean, I do this a lot with my 10-year-old in terms of if she has to give a presentation
这项工作有多少与暴露疗法的理念相关？你知道的，我认为其中贯穿着一个共同的主题，这个理念就是你必须缩短训练与比赛之间的差距。这就是体育类比。你可以把它应用到你所做的任何技能、任何领域，你想习惯真实情境将会是什么样的。所以这意味着，例如，如果你的孩子在打高水平的网球，去现场看他们比赛的第一次不应该是在他们的大型比赛上。
in class, I make her give it to me, and you know, sometimes I make funny comments, or I distract her a little bit, I get her used to what it's going to be like in class, and nothing's more pressure-filled than having your mom embarrass and bother you. So she's ready for it when she gets in front of the group. So in some ways, it seems to me that this is in line with the ideas around how to combat anxiety in general, which is the exposure to the anxiety-inducing trigger is often the best way to reduce our responses to anxiety.
如果你打算去观看练习，他们就需要习惯你在场观看，对吧？这意味着如果你要参加SAT或ACT考试，你必须练习参加SAT和ACT考试。这意味着如果你要当众演讲，你必须练习在有其他人看着你的情况下演讲。
How much of this work is connected to the idea of exposure therapy? You know, I think there's a common theme that runs right through it, and the idea is that you have to close this gap between training and competition. That's the sports analogy. And you can take that to any skill that you do, any domain, you want to get used to what it's going to be like in the real situation. And so that means, for example, if your child is playing high level tennis, the first time to show up to watch them is not at their big match.
你必须习惯这种感觉，并习惯提醒自己，那些生理反应并不是一件坏事。你谈到过，也有一些方法可以重新诠释这些生理反应。换句话说，如果你手心出汗或心跳加速，诠释这些信号的常规方式是告诉自己，天哪，面对当前的情况，我完全应付不来。但对于完全相同的症状，也有另一种思考方式。是的，我的意思是，有趣的是，无论我们是感到担忧还是
They need to get used to you watching them if you're gonna show up at practice, right? It means that if you're gonna take an SAT or an ACT, you've got to practice taking SATs and ACTs. It means if you're gonna speak in public, you've got to practice speaking with other people watching you.
兴奋，我们都会有相同的症状，对吧？这真的是一种极大的解脱，因为这就变成了一种重新诠释。我和其他同事做过大量研究表明，当你能让人们将这些症状重新诠释为他们将要大显身手的迹象时——比如“心跳加速是在把血液输送到我的大脑，这样我才能思考”——而不是将其视为他们将要失败的标志，他们的表现实际上会更好。
You have to get used to what it feels like and get used to reminding yourself that those physiological responses are not a bad thing. You talk about how there are ways to also reframe those physiological responses. In other words, if you're experiencing sweaty palms or a palpitating heart, the normal way to interpret those signals is to tell yourself, oh my god, I am overmatched for the situation that I'm in. But there's a different way to also think about the very same symptoms. Yeah, I mean it's interesting to think about that we'd have the same symptoms whether we were worried or
我们已经针对参加考试的学生证明了这一点，尤其是那些对自己在考试中会表现如何感到非常紧张和焦虑的学生。我们已经证明，实际上，只要让他们重新诠释自己的感受，就能带来更好的表现。西恩，你曾经获得过美国国家科学院颁发的奖项，你当时必须在科学院做一场演讲。你对此感到非常紧张。你能告诉我你是如何运用其中一些技术来应对自己的焦虑的吗？
excited, right? And that's really very liberating because then it's about reinterpreting them. And myself and other colleagues have done a lot of work showing that when you can get people to reinterpret those symptoms as a sign they're going to thrive, that beating hard is shunting blood to my brain so I can think, rather than a sign they're going to fail, they actually perform better.
没错，我的家人都在现场。我妈妈特意从加州飞来。当时的感觉就是，我知道有人在网上观看，我简直吓呆了。当我还是个年轻学者时，我爸妈过去常常来看我做演讲。而我讨厌这样。那种感觉就是，我承受着巨大的压力。
And we've shown this for students taking tests, especially students who are really nervous and anxious about how they're going to do on the test. We've shown that actually just getting them to reinterpret what their feeling leads to better performance. See, you once won an award from the National Academy of Sciences, and you had to give a presentation of the academy. You were very tense about it. Can you tell me how you employed some of these techniques to deal with your own anxiety?
我不得不从物理上把视线从我爸身上移开，因为每一个皱眉或者你知道的任何嘴部动作，都会让我觉得，天哪，我看起来像个白痴。而讽刺的是，往往我们会发现，有家人和朋友都在现场这种友好的面孔，反而会比不认识任何人时制造出更大的压力。所以我提醒自己，我手心出汗和心跳加速并不是一个不好的征兆。我还专注于另一件我认为非常重要的事情，那就是实际上要提醒
Right, my family was there. My mom had flown out from California. It was like, I knew people were watching online, and I was like petrified. My mom and dad used to come watch me talk when I was a young academic. And I hated it. It was like, I was under so much stress.
自己你为什么应该成功。我对材料的了解比任何人都好。即使房间里的每个人都比我聪明得多，我也了解我自己的材料。我是这个领域的专家。而实际上专注于你为什么能够成功，可以带来更好的表现。西恩和其他研究人员还确定了其他技术
I have to like physically turn away from my dad because every like frown or you know, any mouth move and I was like, oh my god, I'm something like an idiot. And oftentimes we actually see ironically that like friendly faces having your family and friends all there can create more pressure than if you didn't know anyone. And so I reminded myself that my sweaty palms and beating heart were not a bad sign. I also focused on something else which I think is really important is that actually reminding
来让运动员和表演者保持心流状态，在这种状态下，他们依靠的是程序性记忆而不是工作记忆，来执行他们已经掌握的任务。防止工作记忆干扰的一个方法是给它一些不重要的任务去做，仅仅是为了让它保持忙碌。好吧，记住，我们讨论过，有时我们在压力下表现不佳，是因为我们开始过多地关注那些我们不该关注的事情，而阻止自己去关注的方法之一就是去做别的事情。
yourself why you should succeed. I know the material better than anyone else. Even if everyone in that room is way smarter than me, I know my own material. I'm the master of this. And actually focusing on why you should succeed can lead to better performance. See on another researchers have also identified other techniques
所以倒数数字、唱一首歌、专注于一个核心想法——在高尔夫运动中人们会有一个挥杆想法——或者如果你在做演讲，专注于你希望人们记住的三个要点。任何能把你的心思从过度分析你所做事情的方方面面中转移开的事情，都非常重要。另一个技巧是专注于你的呼吸。缓慢而深长地呼吸可以让你平静下来。但专注于呼吸也可以将你的工作记忆重定向到除了
to keep athletes and performers in a state of flow, where they are relying on their procedural memory rather than their working memory, to carry out tasks they have already mastered. One way to keep your working memory from interfering is to give it unimportant things to do, just to keep it occupied. Well, remember, we talked about sometimes we perform poorly understress because we start paying too much attention to things that we shouldn't and One of the ways to stop ourselves from paying attention is to do something else
你正在做的事情之外的其他事情上。是的，我的意思是呼吸是另一个我认为非常重要的技巧。它可以把你的心思从你正在做的事情中转移开，这种方式非常好。而且正如你所说，它还能以一种非常重要的方式让你的整个身体平静下来。但我倾向于认为呼吸技巧只是一种极好的拐杖，就像唱歌或专注于你的小脚趾一样，任何能把你的心思从那一刻不该关注的事情上转移开的东西都可以。西恩，你在自己的生活中会这样做吗？
So counting backwards singing a song Focusing on one key thought and golf people have a swing thought Or if you're giving a talk focusing on the three Take home points you want people to get. Anything that takes your mind off of over-analysing every aspect of what you're doing can be really important. Another technique is to focus on your breathing. Breathing slowly and deeply can calm you down. But focusing on your breath can also redirect your working memory to something other than
你在做重要演讲之前，真的会试着在脑海里唱一首歌或者专注于呼吸吗？我会的，我上大学时打长曲棍球，我打中场，所以比赛是以我的争球开始的，这总是让人非常紧张。我唱的是老鹰乐队的《Take It Easy》（放轻松）。我尽量不唱出声来，因为人们会用异样的眼光看我，而且现在每当我
what you are doing. Yeah, I mean the breathing is another, I think, really important technique. It can take your mind off of what you're doing in a way that can be really good. And it can also, again, as you said, calm down your whole body in a way that can be really important. But I tend to think of breathing techniques as a great sort of crutch, just like singing a song or focusing on your pinky toe, anything to take your mind off of what you shouldn't be focusing on in that moment. Do you do this at all, Sian, in your own life?
在需要表现的情境中感到紧张时，这首歌就会自动跳进我的脑海。它就那样自动进来了。Take it easy, take it easy（放轻松，放轻松）。下次我看到你在某个地方做公开演讲时，我就会知道在演讲开始前有什么歌在你脑海里盘旋了。一点没错。就像爱，趁你还拥有时。我在重大活动前做的另一件事是分散自己的注意力，这似乎有点违反直觉，但我认为提前10分钟绝对不是临时抱佛脚或者思考
Do you actually try and sing a song in your head or focus on your breathing before you give an important presentation? I do, so I played lacrosse in college and I was center, so I started the game with the draw and it was always really nerve-wracking. And I sang Take It Easy by the Eagles. I tried not to do it out loud because people would look me weird, and the song pops into
你到底要怎么投出那一球的时候。而是去做一些完全不同的事情。我知道很多职业运动员都这样做，听音乐，有的人做纵横字谜。我喜欢在网上看一些《人物》杂志，做一些能完全把我的心思从我要去的地方转移开的事情。我们讨论过训练有素的音乐家和运动员是如何发挥失常的。你可以从中得出的一个结论是，练习和经验对于防止发挥失常并不是很有用。那可就大错特错了。
my head now when I get nervous in situations where I have to perform. It comes in there automatically. Take it easy, take it easy. The next time I see you giving a public talk somewhere, I'll know what song is going through your head right before the talk begins. Exactly. Like love while you still can. Another thing I do right before a big event is I distract myself, which seems a little bit counterintuitive, but I'd argue that 10 minutes before is not the time to cram or to think
我认为练习非常重要。练习对于培养流畅自动化的行为过程以及你正在做的事情至关重要。练习通常所做的是，让你不必专注于你所做事情的每一个步骤和每一个细节。如果你在玩游戏时能做到这一点，
about exactly how you're going to shoot the shot. It's to do something totally different. I know a lot of professional athletes do this, listen to music, some do crossword puzzles. I like to read some people magazine online, something that just takes my mind off completely of where I'm going. We've talked about how highly trained musicians and athletes can choke. One conclusion you might draw from this is that practice and experience are not very useful in preventing choking. That would be a mistake.
比如说，那么你更有可能表现出色。而具有讽刺意味的是，你更不容易记住你刚才做了什么。我总是开玩笑说，当运动员在经历了一场伟大而精彩的比赛后接受采访时，他们能想到的只有感谢他们的妈妈。他们总是这样做，
I think practice is so important. Practice is really important for developing fluent automated processes and what you're doing. And what the practice does often is allow you not to have to focus on every step and every detail of what you're doing. And if you can do that
因为他们不记得自己做了什么。他们不知道该说什么。我的意思是，我不知道该说什么。这是因为他们的表现太自动化了，几乎处于有意识的觉知之外，当你对某事不予关注时，你就记不住它。当你学习一项技能时，它也可能很重要。西恩曾做过一项研究，分析了高尔夫球手开始打球时的年龄。
when you're playing a game, for example, then you are more likely to perform well. And ironically, you're less likely to remember what you just did. I always make a joke that when athletes are interviewed after a great and fantastic game, all they can do is think they're moms. They do that all the time,
所以我的研究和其他人的研究表明，当人们在很小的时候就开始学习时，他们通常能够免受在这些特别是运动技能中发挥失常的影响。这几乎就像他们学习的方式不同，在最重要的时候他们更不容易慌乱。你认为大脑中发生了什么导致了这种情况的发生？嗯，我们知道很多时候
because they don't remember what they did. They don't know what to say. I mean, I don't know what to say. And it's because they were performing so automatically, it was actually almost outside of conscious awareness and when you don't pay attention to something, you don't remember it. When you learn a skill, it can also matter. Cion once conducted a study where she analyzed the age at which golfer started to play the game.
当儿童学习活动时，他们是以一种更自动化的方式学习的。他们不会去想他们所做事情的每一个步骤。想想小孩子是如何学习一语言的，对吧？它只是那种渗透进去了。有时当你以这种方式学习时，你某种程度上就可以免受那种能够解构并破坏你表现的方式的影响。西恩，我想知道你能否谈谈你在大学里那次化学考试考砸时的情景。掠过你脑海的想法不是，你知道的，我复习的方法不对。掠过你脑海的想法是，我其实并不属于大学。你不禁会想，这种情况发生在其他人身上的频率有多高——那些觉得压力
So my research and others have shown that when people learn actually really early, they often are protected from choking in these sorts of especially motor skills. It's almost as if they learn it differently and they're less likely to flood when it matters most. What do you think is happening in the brain that causes this to happen? Well, we know that oftentimes
已经压垮了他们，并觉得自己在这个环境中格格不入的人。我们能否聊聊发挥失常也可能受到我们的家庭、组织和文化塑造的这个观点？我的意思是，是否存在某些环境比其他环境更容易产生发挥失常？你知道的，我认为这是一个非常棒的问题，因为它切中了一个重要点：尽管我们花了很多时间讨论
when children learn activities, they learn them more in a more automatic fashion. They're not thinking about every step of what they're doing. Think about how to kid learns a language, right? It's just sort of seeping in. And sometimes when you learn it in that way, you're sort of protected from essentially being able to unpack it in a way that disrupts your performance. I'm wondering, Sihan, if you can talk a moment about when you did badly on that chemistry test in college. The thought that went through your mind was not, you know, I prepared for this the wrong way. The thought that went through your mind was, I don't really belong in college. And you have to wonder how often that's happening to other people, people who feel like the pressure
我们脑海里发生了什么，但我们脑海里发生的事情其实深受我们所处环境的影响，对吧？所以如果我们走进一个情境，并且觉得我们不应该表现好，因为我们历史上一直被排斥，或者我们是房间里唯一的女性，或者人们觉得我们不应该表现好。这会对我们的表现产生影响。但如果我们走进同一个情境，并且觉得即使我们表现得不是那么好，
has gotten to them, and they feel like they're out of place in a situation. Can we talk about the idea that choking can also be shaped by our families, organizations, and cultures? I mean, are there some environments that are more likely to produce choking than others? You know, I think this is really a great question because it hits on an important point that even though we're talking a lot about
人们也知道我们可以学习并变得更好，过去也有人表现不好但最终安然无恙的例子，我们有途径去提问而不被评判。这突然之间就能改变人们对自己能力的态度。环境对我们的感受有很大的影响
what's happening inside our head, what's happening inside our head is really affected by the environment that we're in, right? So if we walk into a situation and we feel like we shouldn't perform well because we've been historically excluded or with the only woman in the room, or people don't feel like we should do well. That can have an impact on how we perform. But if we walk into the same situation and feel like even if we don't do so well,
关于我们自己，从本质上讲，也就决定了我们有多大可能发挥失常。几个月前我们在《隐藏的大脑》中采访了克劳德·斯蒂尔，他的很多工作都聚焦于刻板印象威胁的理念，即当你身上或你所在的群体身上存在刻板印象时，在某种程度上你变得更有可能去证明这些刻板印象是真的，因为你太担心这些刻板印象了，太担心去证明刻板印象是真的，以至于你的表现最终受到了阻碍。
people know that we can learn and get better, that there are examples of people not doing well in the past and being okay, that there's avenues for us to ask questions and not be judged. It all of a sudden can change people's attitude about what they can do. The environment has a big effect on how we feel
在某种程度上，我想这不完全是发挥失常，但它是一种相关的现象。是的，我的意思是，我一直向克劳德辩论说，刻板印象威胁其实就是发挥失常的一种形式。我认为它是。我不知道他是否同意我的看法，但在我看来它确实是，至少因为环境本质上正在对你在那一刻如何看待自己产生影响。
about ourselves, and in essence, then how likely we are to choke. We interviewed Claude Steele on Hidden Brain some months ago, and a lot of his work focuses on the idea of stereotype threat, which is that when you have stereotypes about you or your group, in some ways you become more likely to prove those stereotypes true because you're so worried about the stereotypes, so worried about showing that the stereotype is true, that your performance ends up becoming impeded.
你本质上是想摆脱别人对你的某种期望。你担心基于你来自的任何群体而被评估。这会影响你如何诠释当前的情境。它会影响你关注什么。并且还会影响你如何诠释你的身体反应。如果我手心出汗、心跳加速，
In some ways it's not quite choking, I suppose, but it's sort of a related phenomenon. Yeah, I mean, I've always argued to cloud that stereotype threat is just a form of choking. I think it is. I don't know if he agrees with me, but it is, in my mind, at least because the environment is essentially having an effect on how you think about yourself in that moment.
而且我很高兴去做某事，并且我已经准备好出发了，这实际上会带来更好的表现。但如果我手心出汗、心跳加速，并且我担心证实这种刻板印象，我的表现实际上可能会变差。所以我很好奇我们应该如何看待个人应该做些什么。换句话说，当你们在交谈时我注意到的一点是，在某种程度上，对某些人来说，局势的对垒是不公平的。
You want to essentially live down some expectation that someone else has. You're worried about being evaluated based on whatever group you come from. And that can affect how you interpret the situation. It can affect what you focus on. And can also affect how you interpret your bodily reactions. If I have a sweaty palms and beating heart,
例如，如果你是第一代大学生，你在大学里感受到的压力可能比家里多代人都有过大学经历的人要大。因此你更有很可能发挥失常，但很明显，这部分是结构性和环境因素的结果，而这些是你无法控制的。但当然，我们在某种程度上仍然依靠个人来解决这些问题，因为我们将发挥失常的问题归咎于个人。这里确实存在某种张力，不是吗？—即将发挥失常视为一种个人现象与将发挥失常视为一种结构性现象之间的张力。
and I am excited to do something, and I'm ready to go, that will actually lead to better performance. But if I have a sweaty palms and beating heart, and I'm worried about confirming the stereotype, my performance might actually get worse. So I'm wondering how we should think about what individuals should do. So in other words, I think one of the things that I was picking up as you were talking is that in some ways the deck is stacked unfairly against some people.
是的，我的意思是，我觉得你真的说得很对，我认为它在被研究的大多数情况下是一种个人现象，但它也是一种结构性现象，在你给出的那个例子中，我会认为这是组织的责任——即学院或大学——去认识到可能存在这种情况，并开始建立结构来帮助确保
If you're a first-generation college student, for example, you might be experiencing more pressure being in college than if multiple members of your family have been to college over several generations. And so you're more likely to choke, but it's clear that it's partly the result of structural and environmental factors, or which you have no control. But of course, we are relying on individuals in some ways to address those problems because we're locating the problem of choking in individuals. There is some tension there, is there not, between sort of thinking about choking as an individual phenomenon and the problem of choking as a structural phenomenon.
那些进来的学生，比如第一代大学生，他们可能会觉得自己不应该表现得很好，但他们能拥有支持从而做到这一点。在巴纳德学院，我们刚刚启动了一个全新的办公室和倡议，叫做“访问巴纳德”，专门面向第一代低收入和国际学生，旨在做到你刚刚谈论的事情，
Yeah, I mean, I think you're really right, and I think it's an individual phenomenon in how it's mostly been studied, but it is also a structural phenomenon and there, in the example you gave, I would argue that it is the organization's responsibility, the College of University, to recognize that that might be the case and to start putting structures in place to help ensure
也就是本质上承担一些我所认为的他们所肩负的额外认知负荷或负担，因为他们可能不那么熟悉美国的最高高等教育。我要说的是，能力远比机会更普遍。当我们思考如何确保每个具备这种能力的人都能坐在谈判桌前并茁壮成长时，作为组织领导者和组织，我们必须考虑这些结构。
that those students who come in say, first-generation, who might feel as if they shouldn't perform as well, have supports so that they can. At Barnard, we just started a whole new office and initiative called Access Barnard, that is for first-generation low-income and international students, designed to do exactly what you're talking about,
这不能仅仅是个人的责任。西恩，我想知道你能否花一点时间谈谈一些关注飞机驾驶舱的研究，例如，与50或60年前相比，今天的飞机驾驶舱的设计假定飞行员会犯错误。驾驶舱的目标不是说，除非你做到完美，否则会有不好的事情发生在你身上。驾驶舱现在的目标是说，我们知道事情不时会出故障。我们知道飞行员会犯错误。驾驶舱现在的目标是将这些错误降到最低。
which is essentially take some of the extra cognitive load or burden I would argue that they shoulder about not necessarily being as familiar with American higher education. And I would say that, you know, ability is way more widespread than opportunity. And as we think about how to make sure that everyone with that ability is able to be at the table and thrive, we have to, as organizational leaders and as organizations, think about the structures.
其次，当错误发生时，将这些错误的后果降到最低。对于这一系列研究，是否存在某种社会层面的启示？也就是探讨我们如何能够总体上普遍减少压力。是的，我的意思是，我喜欢这种思路。我的意思是，这有点像人生的目标不应该是不犯错误。而应该是我们会犯错误，以及我们如何恢复、减少（你知道的）其影响。我认为这在许多情况下都是正确的。所以我认为驾驶舱就是一个很好的例子。我也认为这适用于人们领导组织的方式。例如，领导者
It can't just be an individual responsibility. I'm wondering, Sihan, if we can talk a moment about some of the work that's looked at airline cockpits, for example, compared to 50 or 60 years ago, airline cockpits today are designed to assume that pilots are going to make mistakes. The goal of the cockpit is not to say, unless you're perfect, something bad is going to happen to you. The goal of the cockpit now is to say, we know that things are going to fail from time to time. We know that pilots are going to make mistakes. The goal of the cockpit now is to minimize those mistakes.
谈论他们犯过的错误，以任何某种程度上让人们可以犯错误并学习和成长的方式。你想讨论的是，如何才能做到这一点——我们教育人们如何将事故发生时的影响降到最低，或者如何将伤害降到最低，以及如何从中吸取教训，如何大声说出来，并知道一个错误并不是世界末日。
And secondly, when the mistakes happen, to minimize the consequences of those mistakes. Is there a sort of societal implication for this body of work, which is talking about the ways in which we can generally reduce pressure overall. Yeah, I mean, I love this line of thinking. I mean, it's sort of like the goal of life shouldn't be that we're not going to make mistakes. It should be that we are going to make mistakes and how do we recover, reduce, you know, the impact. And I think that's true in so many situations. So I think the cockpit is a great example. I also think it's true in how people lead organizations. So leaders, for example,
西恩，你认为作为一个社会，我们在某种程度上也美化了压力吗？我们在某种程度上将那些能够在压力下表现出色的人视为杰出人才？我的意思是，显然有些情况下你需要非常善于应对压力的人。如果你是一名消防员，你绝对希望消防员能够在压力下做出很好的反应，因为据推测那是消防员在做他们最重要的工作的时候。但在生活中有许多情况，我觉得我们用压力来测试人们
talking about the mistakes they've made, any way that sort of makes it okay for people to make mistakes and learn and grow. And what you wanna be talking about is how can you make it so we're educating people about how to minimize when an accident happens or minimize injury and how to learn from it and how to speak up and know that one mistake is not the end of the world.
进入某些职业。而这些职业实际上并不需要太多的压力下运作能力，这就引出了一个问题：为什么我们要用压力情境来评估人们。是的，我的意思是，我认为这是一个非常公平的观点。我的论点是，我们不应该用任何单一的情境来决定人们是否成功，或者他们是否可以继续前行，或者他们是否胜任这项工作。
Do you think that as a society, we also glorify pressure to some extent, Cyan, that in some ways we credit people who are able to do well under pressure as being exceptional? I mean, there are clearly situations where you want people who are very good at dealing with pressure. If you're a firefighter, you definitely want firefighters to be able to respond well under pressure because presumably that's when the firefighters are doing their most important work. But there are many situations in life where I feel like we use pressure to test people
你知道，在课堂上，巴纳德学院的许多教授已经从仅仅进行期中和期末考试，转变为在整个季度或学期中进行多次评估。事实证明，当你对人们进行多次评估时，他们实际上学得更多，因为参加考试也是一个了解自己懂什么、不懂什么的过程。但它也提供了一个更全面的图景。
into professions. And those professions actually don't call for a lot of functioning under pressure, which begs the question of why we're using pressure situations to evaluate people. Yeah, I mean, I think it's a really fair point. What I would argue is that we shouldn't be using anyone situation to decide whether people succeed or whether they can go on or whether they're fit for the job.
我认为这在各行各业都是如此。我的意思是，我认为工作面试或这些评估情况之所以只是一锤子买卖的原因之一，是因为这样更容易操作。但问题是，更容易操作真的能带给你最好的结果吗？我认为通常答案是否定的。[♪ 背景音乐播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放中，播放器里面。
You know, in classrooms, many of our professors at Barnard have stepped away from just having a midterm and a final to multiple assessments throughout the quarter, or the semester. It turns out that when you assess people multiple times, they actually learn more because taking a test is also a place to learn what you know and what you don't know. But it also gives a whole more holistic picture.
你知道，在课堂上，巴纳德学院的许多教授已经从仅仅设置期中和期末考试转变为在整个季度或学期中进行多次评估。事实证明，当你对人们进行多次评估时，他们实际上学到了更多，因为参加测试也是一个了解自己会什么、不会什么的地方。但它也提供了更全面的图景。
And I think that's true across the board. I mean, I think one reason that we, that job interviews or these assessment situations are just one shot, it's because it's easier to do it that way. But the question is, does easier lead you essentially to the best outcome? And I think oftentimes the answer is no. [♪ Music playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing me today on Hidden Brain. Oh, it was so fun. Thank you. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Laura Quarelle, Kristen Wong, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, and Andrew Chadwick. Tara Boyle is our executive producer.
我认为全面来看确实如此。我的意思是，我认为我们之所以采用求职面试或这种只有一次机会的评估情况，其中一个原因是这样更容易做到。但问题是，更容易真的能带给你最好的结果吗？我认为通常答案是否定的。[♪ 背景音乐播放中...] 感谢今天邀请我来到“隐藏的大脑”。哦，这太有趣了。谢谢。“隐藏的大脑”由“隐藏的大脑”传媒制作。我们的制作团队包括布里奇特·麦卡锡、劳拉·夸雷尔、克里斯滕·王、瑞安·卡茨、奥特姆·巴恩斯和安德鲁·查德里克。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。
I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. Our run song here this week is Sendul Muleinathan. He's a researcher at the University of Chicago and a friend of the show. He told me some time ago about how cockpits were redesigned to take pilot error into account and how we should think of designing other systems like our schools and hospitals with the same insight. I've always found Sender to be a great source of ideas and inspiration. Thanks Sender. If you like this episode, please be sure to share it with three friends. If you are new to podcasting, please show them how to subscribe to our show. I'm Shankar Vidantam.
我是“隐藏的大脑”的执行主编。我们本周的特约嘉宾是森杜尔·穆莱纳坦。他是芝加哥大学的研究员，也是节目的老朋友。不久前，他告诉我座舱是如何被重新设计以将飞行员失误考虑在内的，以及我们应该如何以同样的洞察力去思考设计学校和医院等其他系统。我一直发现森杜尔是创意和灵感的绝佳来源。谢谢你，森杜尔。如果你喜欢这期节目，请务必与三位朋友分享。如果你是播客新手，请向他们展示如何订阅我们的节目。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。
See you next week. I make a point to not focus on metals or times because that's very outcome dependent. But if I can hit the wall, and I can say that is the best performance that I could have given on this day, and I did it under pressure, under the lights, in a final of a race, then I can walk away happy whatever the result. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
下周见。我特别注意不把焦点放在奖牌或时间上，因为那很大程度上取决于结果。但如果我能触壁，并且可以说那是我在那一天能够发挥出的最佳水平，而且我是顶着压力、在灯光下、在决赛中做到的，那么无论结果如何，我都可以开心地离开。目前还没有关于这一集的评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。